all right here's the story from
timcast.com Supreme Court finds
affirmative action unconstitutional says
School cannot consider race during
admission Chief Justice John Roberts
wrote Harvard and UNC concluded wrongly
to the Touchstone of an individual's
identity is not challenges bested skills
built or Lessons Learned but the color
of their skin
the Court ruled universities and
colleges cannot weigh an applicant's
race during the admissions process the
majority of the justices found
affirmative action policies unavoidable
unavoidably employ race in a negative
manner involve racial stereotyping and
lack meaningful endpoints we have never
permitted admissions programs to work in
that way and we will not do so today
stated the court two appeals regarding
the constitutionality of affirmative
action have been appealed to the Supreme
Court one brought by the University of
North Carolina was blocked six to three
and one brought by Harvard University
was rejected 62. Justice katanji Brown
Jackson did not vote on the latter
the ruling released on June 29th
overturns a previous decision made in
the grudder v Bollinger in 2003 at the
time the Supreme Court found that race
could be weighed as a factor in missions
because universities had a compelling
interest in maintaining diverse campuses
the Supreme Court is right what you need
to understand very very simply is that
in order for affirmative action to work
the Assumption must be that certain
races are inherently worse than other
races which is just not true at least I
don't believe our government should be
operating that I don't believe it but I
think the left absolutely does I'm
seeing a bunch of tweets from people
on the left
the racism pouring out of these liberals
brains is insane people these people are
tweeting things about like well how will
how will minorities succeed now
hard work and and and what do you mean
they always succeeded the same way so
many other immigrants who have come to
this country have succeeded by working
really hard and making a better future
for their children
it's amazing isn't it well it's
incredibly infantilizing I've talked
about affirmative action in the past
I've even done that an educational video
about it and one thing I want to mention
is well the obvious clear Injustice with
affirmative action and the thing
conservatives should talk about most
loudly is is not the soft bigotry of low
expectation but the fact that white
students and Asian students are kept
from having positions that they have
merited because students who didn't
Merit those positions were given them on
the basis of their ethnic makeup it is
also true that these policies are not
good for minorities or people in these
communities so what will happen and this
is something Thomas Soules talked about
this is something we did a research
video on for Freedom Tunes a while back
what happens is
a black student will end up being placed
in a classroom and in a school setting
that is beyond his academic
qualifications and so he'll end up
dropping out more often because he isn't
in a classroom that actually matches
what his standardized testing scores
tell us he's going to be capable of
achieving academically so for example if
you have a black kid who could get into
a really impressive school but not
necessarily Harvard and then affirmative
action bumps him up and puts them into
Harvard the likelihood that he's going
to drop out of Harvard is greater than
the likelihood that he would have
dropped out of the institution that he
was more qualified to attend and then
he's less likely to get a degree so but
to clarify while you are correct in the
context of this they're targeting
minorities what you're saying applies to
literally any person of any race if you
take any person of any race who scores
low on an entrance exam and then put
them in a more advanced program yes
they're likely to drop from that program
and so what these programs were doing
was was one Bay seeing the entire
admission structure on on the on the
idea that certain races just inherently
and I mean it when I say inherent the
left always tries to make the argument
that when you're talking about race or
crime stats so like you think inherently
no no
the pretext for affirmative action is
inherent because they're saying all
people they're outright saying that if
you are Asian you can't come into this
school because you scored this on this
test as if all Asians are the same so
what ends up happening is they're
Latinos and and black Americans will
score at a certain level and probably
qualify for some good schools and
they'll say put them in an Ivy League
where they struggle drop out and are
worse off for it well it's such a
strange thing if you're concerned is
that there's not enough minority
representation in Academia then what you
have to do is try to structure things so
that they're they're going through the
public school system or whatever private
school system is available to them in
such a way that they end up being
qualified to attend these institutions
you don't slap a Band-Aid over it by
pushing them into institutions that
they're not qualified to attend I think
the the problem that affirmative action
is trying to solve is is
making up for the last 150 years of the
black uh citizenry of the United States
being descended from slaves not having
access to parental education like you're
the great great grandfathers were you
know slaves and didn't have did not read
and write and then they had kids that if
the parent doesn't know how to read and
write you know education's passed down a
lot of times from the adult to the child
so they're trying to solve this I guess
you would call it a class-based issue
because these people were treated as
second-class Citizens when they were
enslaved for in 1830. so it's trying to
give these people now like push them
into the the level but I think I agree
with that you're saying that you just
can't force people into higher education
and expect them to succeed I just need
to earn it I disagree I think you're
giving too much benefit of the doubt to
these people since the 50s when we
started seeing the rise of social
programs we've seen what appears to be
something beneficial that causes harm
like Sheamus is pointing out any person
who scores low who is put into a an
advanced program will likely struggle
with it and it will cause them harm I do
not believe these people are ignorant of
that fact when they have Decades of data
to show it I think many of these people
are intentionally trying to cause harm
because they're overtly racist
absolutely and we saw all throughout
2020 that the left one wants a race war
they want to inflame uh division between
uh the races and the classes and I think
it's pretty sick and I think that
affirmative action is one of the most
racist policies that we've ever seen in
Dei and race-based hiring is also uh in
fact racist people should be hired and
accepted based on merits and not based
on ethnicity or color two examples I'll
give you Ian one there's a viral video
of two white women vandalizing a black
neighborhood and two black women come
together and say stop destroying our
neighborhood and the antifa liberal
women go no no we're doing this for you
the the far leftists would go into
minority neighborhoods and assist in the
destruction I was there in Ferguson and
I'm asking myself myself
why are you people destroying this black
neighborhood they wrote there was a
leftist who wrote an article after
Ferguson in defense of looting and made
the argument that they were eluding
these buildings the that black people
were looting buildings because it was
resistance to the to the machine that
was oppressing them the reality the
people who lived in the community linked
arms to protect their businesses from
outside looters so why are these people
in the media lying over and over again
about it perhaps it's because they're
overt racists who know they're not going
to be able to pull off these things if
they come out and say hey their real
plan is to hurt people they need to act
like they're doing good don't get me
wrong there probably are a lot of dumb
default liberals who think they're doing
good but I think the people organizing
this know exactly what they're doing
absolutely and you know they're
attacking uh the Supreme Court Justices
as the racist in reality the people who
support affirmative action are the
racist but it's ridiculous to say that
the Supreme Court Justices are racist
because they were appointed by the least
racist president in American history a
report by Reuters just came out and it
said that Donald J Trump is the only
living president who is not a direct
descendant of slave owners so Obama's a
direct descendant of slave owners Joe
Biden's a direct descendant of slave
owners uh Jimmy Carter the bushes Donald
Trump appointed the Supreme Court
Justices who helped overturn Roe v Wade
therefore they are the least racist
Supreme Court justices in America in my
opinion and possibly you know in
writer's opinion as well I saw this
story I met this black dude who was
anti-trump and we were having this
discussion this was in New York and he
said Donald Trump is the least racist
president this country has ever had and
I was like oh that's an interesting
thing to say aren't you against Trump
and he's like yeah yeah look Trump's
still racist but you gotta admit he's
the least racist president and then I
was like well lab Brittany goes yo
president's own slaves and I was like
Fair Point fair point so his his point
was Trump is better than we've ever seen
but there's still work to be done and
I'm kind of like okay he was chill about
it you know I can respect that well he
shared the Reuters report day Trump did
that was hilarious no I I thought it was
hilarious I think it's like obviously a
funny way to troll one thing that I
found very entertaining is the reaction
from a lot of democratic politicians
with affirmative action being overturned
by the court so Gavin Newsom says they
want to whitewash our nation's history
they want to bring back to the they want
to bring America back to the era of book
Bannings and segregated campuses we
cannot let them AOC well first I'll read
you uh Elizabeth Warren she said an
extremist Supreme Court has once again
reversed Decades of settled law and she
goes on to Bello a bit more and then my
personal favorite AOC said if scotus was
serious about their ludicrous color
blindness claims they would have
abolished legacy admissions AKA
affirmative action for the privileged 70
of Harvard's Legacy applicants are white
scotus didn't touch that which would
have impacted them and their patrons I
don't even know where to begin with that
AOC the court was not deciding on legacy
admissions at universities
well Viva fry makes a good point with
the top comment saying 71 percent of
America is white silly yeah so it's
actually an underrepresentation at
Harvard that's also a very good point
but to say well the Supreme a the
Supreme Court didn't touch that and then
also with something no one expected them
to touch that wasn't on the table and
then it would have impacted them and
their patrons as if the Supreme Court
that is unelected people are making
these decisions because uh they're
they're like bought and sold to make
this decision that's why that why um
they they decided to overturn
affirmative action but didn't say Legacy
applicants or Legacy applicants so these
are people whose children parents went
to the university yeah well it's
important to remember that Elizabeth
Warren lied about being Native American
to get hired at Harvard which propelled
her to you take that back yes that's not
true she is one one thousand twenty
fourth Native American I believe well of
course of course she's defending
affirmative action because you know she
game the system to yeah I know at Javit
Harvard and then become ultimately a U.S
senator and so but what was it she was
actually one one thousand yeah something
like I'm sorry please don't sue me
Elizabeth you are Native American one
1024 well no no oh no but here's what we
can say here's what we can say the
Cherokee Nation told her she could not
call herself Cherokee because what
happened was she got this blood test
back that shown showed that she was a
very very very tiny fraction Native
American and she said see this means I'm
Cherokee that's like saying well my DNA
test said that I have European blood in
me therefore I'm Italian what are you
talking about that's a much more
specific claim right but she's like like
yeah but so she's pointing to a specific
tribe and saying I have indigenous
American DNA therefore I can claim
membership in this tribe that's not how
it works but it's more than that it's
like saying I have European industry
therefore I'm a British citizen exactly
that's right yes no yes no yes yeah I'm
a British citizen my DNA test uh said
that I Time 1 1000th British so I guess
I'm a citizen now and the Cherokee
Nation was like no no no thank you I
can't believe she tried to pull that off
but if she wants to Trump shoulder is
what happens what's hilarious is that
Elizabeth Warren is partially
responsible for restarting a national
conversation about why affirmative
action is bad uh you know as president
Trump started calling her Pocahontas
right and everybody's like why is she
calling her Pocahontas well she lied
about her race and ethnicity to get into
uh get a job at a school and there was a
CNN interview that I shared this morning
it was from 2017 where an admissions
consultant uh was debating why we need
to ban affirmative action and he
predicted in 2017 that President Donald
Trump will be the president to end it
he's going to use the justice department
to sue these schools which he did he
sued Yale uh and then he also said he's
gonna appoint three constitutional
conservative justices who will uh
overturn affirmative action and so that
guy on CNN was a was a prophet and so
but thank you Elizabeth Warren because
she also deserves some credit in
overturning affirmative action due to
being exposed as a liar look at the New
York Times wrote they said breaking the
Supreme Court rejected affirmative
action affirmative action as Harvard at
Harvard and UNC the major ruling
curtails race race conscious College
admissions in the U.S all but ensuring
that Elite institutions become whiter
and more Asian and less black this is
what I want to talk about in a whatever
my goodness because what I'm going to
say might come off as a defensive
affirmative action I used to hate that
when I first learned about it in 1993 we
were teenagers in high school we would
sit around talking like wait if I apply
for a job and I have a better score
they're going to hire a black guy that's
not as good as me and they're like yeah
my friends are like yeah we're like
that's Reverse Racism which turns out
years later we start to realize it's
actually just racism why don't I get in
but okay here's the situation there's a
hundred of us us we all live on a city
block uh us and 100 years ago super
racist the black people were allowed to
go to school they were kept as slaves so
their kids didn't have access to
education they had really crappy food
really small the their brains didn't
develop as much as they had poor
nutrition now 30 40 50 years later their
kids same thing they didn't have a lot
of access to food nutrition now it's
today and they're like we're going to
hire the smartest people on the Block
well it's the people that have
ancestrally the best access to nutrition
and education that are going to be
considered the best at and so naturally
to people with the most the healthiest
ancestors are going to get the crack at
it and what they're trying to do is to
balance it out so like sorry your
ancestors didn't have access to
education but but that's like the fairy
tale version of what they're doing which
is not what they're doing they're
hitting with the Mallet it's not working
the way you solve this is class based so
what's actually happening is you have
impoverished well you say Chicago as an
example you have impover impoverished
areas with a higher density of of black
people what the left does is they look
at the neighborhood see black people and
then think the race is the reason which
is racist they then start saying
insanely racist things but there's also
Latino
Eastern European immigrants white people
living in these areas as well so here's
what ends up happening because the
people who can only see race who are
racist and have always been racist think
the solution of the problem is more
racism they go into a neighborhood that
may be 70 black and 20 white and they
say all of the black people here are
going to get a special benefit so that
we can put them in better institutions
and then their their neighbors their
equals and their peers who are not black
or who are you know Latino or white or
whatever are sitting there holding empty
bags saying What About Us
then what happens when you have people
of different racial backgrounds and this
the state comes in and gives money
literally to one racial group
in these areas I'll tell you what
happens the racial group that doesn't
get the benefit
they they keep engaging in the crime
they typically engage in but they target
people with money so you end up with
other people being like hey this race is
attacking this race all it does is make
racial tensions worse the real solution
is as you're in your analogy 100 people
living on a block you know 80 percent of
or 80 of them are working at the best
Institutions and are wealthy and they
say we want to we want to make sure
everyone's got an equal to opportunity
what do we do I know those of a certain
income bracket then they walk into the
portion of their street where it's a
higher density of black latino for
historic reasons and they say to
everyone there including the poor white
people the poor immigrants the poor
Latinos the poor Asians doesn't matter
what your race is we're here to help all
of you so would it be I think it would
still be a bad idea if Harvard were to
let people in that were poor at a higher
rate with the same test scores maybe not
no it's about letting people in who are
poor with the appropriate test scores
but waving certain fees and giving them
scholarships the idea is if you should
be here we're going to make sure you can
be here just because you're poor
something you deserve to go to Harvard
but if we want to help break the cycle
of poverty we find the diamond in the
rough in these areas and we say you have
real potential and the only thing
holding you back is that your parents
won't have the money we're going to
cover those costs for you that's how you
actually solve these problems and if the
left actually believed they believed
about historical racism and
institutional racism that policy right
there would disproportionately help
Black and Latino individuals you would
not need affirmative action so I can
only conclude either they're stupid or
they're lying and the reality may be a
mixture of both yeah yeah I think that's
right I'll also add this part of what
affirmative action does is it recenters
our thinking about the purpose of having
a career the purpose about of going
through an academic institution the
purpose of being admitted to a college
right the reason that Society sanctions
these things the reason Society gives a
person the position of privilege and
esteem that it is to be a student at one
of these universities is because they
believe that that student is going to be
able to contribute and the reason they
have good evidence to believe that that
student's going to have something to
contribute at the level that they're
being given that honor is because of
their test scores because of their
academic history these things the
purpose of social positions is not to
make the person in the social position
feel special for having the social
position the purpose of a social
position is to find what we can get from
other people
what's a social position in this just
like I mean anything uh a job a position
as a student right with anything uh
anything anything that Society carves
out and says this is what this person
does we're either going to hire you for
an employer or we're going to elect you
if you're someone running for office or
we are going to give you this seat at
our University if we're admitting you
the whole purpose of it is this is
somebody who if we give this position to
will be able to contribute to society
Society in a way such that it'll make it
better not let's give this person this
position so they can feel special here's
the other thing
imagine there was a neighborhood that
was uh lower income and these leftists
are like these poor people they should
go to college okay for what
go to college for what yeah what what
what what job or career or plan so they
go into this poor area and they say we
want to give you guys college and the
poor guy says this area is working class
industrial Factory we are some of the
best in these areas the amount of money
generated from these factories is lower
than the ivy league areas that doesn't
just because they may make less money
doesn't mean everyone should just be in
college some some like what we want to
do is we want to maximize people's
talents and abilities we want to make
sure that everybody's getting their best
opportunity so if someone is from a
neighborhood that typically is working
class but they clearly show an affinity
for the law we want to make sure that
they have an opportunity to reach that
the left just says we want more people
of Race To Be an institution which just
makes no sense
what they're really saying is we want
less white kids and less Asian kids at
these institutions well it's the Asian
thing for the most part the uh
you know I I've talked to leftists about
this quite a bit and I'm and I always I
always end by saying after they agree
with all of this all right fine have it
your way but you have to be the one to
look the poor Asian kid in the eyes and
say I'm sorry kid you don't get to go to
college because you look too much like
that guy yeah that's their arguments
well I'm sorry that little kid looks
like that little kid therefore only one
of them gets to go to college well I was
talking how does that make sense I was
talking to a friend of mine uh who he's
a white guy who's married to a Mexican
woman and they have a son together and
uh he was looking for private schools in
New York City
and he his son's complexion looks more
like his white father's than it does his
Mexican moms and they said actually you
know
you you don't look the part like we
can't support you financially and give
you some breaks because you don't look
uh the right color and so even though
he's half Hispanic which would
technically qualify him but he doesn't
he doesn't look Hispanic he doesn't get
uh a lower rate for tuition uh as the
Hispanic kids and so you know it's just
like people are getting fed up with this
I think the affirmative action uh being
overturned is going to be incredibly
popular with the American public I think
a lot of parents a lot of white parents
a lot of Asian parents they've kind of
held their tongue because they don't
want to be called racist by uh their
woke liberal friends but these college
campuses are turning into hell holes as
well I had a family member who graduated
from the University of Wisconsin-Madison
so I went to the graduation in May
and some student on campus uh just from
random student got caught using the
n-word it was a white girl who used the
n-word so 10 minutes out of the
graduation two black girls got up on on
stage welcomed by the dean and she
lectured these students lectured about
how racist the University of
Wisconsin-Madison is and how much
progress they still need to make and so
these girls are lecturing the entire
graduating class and the 50 000 parents
and family members that are in
attendance about how racist the
community is and how much University of
Wisconsin sucks and they just let it
happen I'm like what the hell is going
on these places yeah well there's a kind
of self-flagellation that every
left-wing institution has to partake in
we're so racist we're so horrible we're
so sorry that type of thing I mean they
almost feel as if it's a kind of and I
shouldn't say they almost feel this way
it is I mean it's just a virtue signal
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time